in everyday language we know what a kite
means it's these flimsy things that we
take to the beach to fly in the wind
with our families but you could imagine
mathematicians have looked at the
general shape of these kites or at least
the way that they've draw they're drawn
in cartoons they said well that's an
interesting shape in its own right let's
also make this a mathematical term this
is a shape like a parallelogram or like
a rhombus it's just another type of
quadrilateral but in order for it to
have to be used in mathematics in a
useful way we have to define it a little
bit more price precisely so let's see if
we can come up with a couple of
interesting definitions of what a kite
could be or a couple of interesting ways
to construct a kite
well one way that you could think about
a kite is it looks like it has two pairs
of sides that are congruent to each
other so for example it looks like this
side and this side need to be congruent
to each other
so let's make that a constraint
and they touch each other they have a
shared common endpoint so you have one
pair of congruent sides that's adjacent
to each other they have this common
endpoint and then you have another pair
of sides
you have another pair of sides that are
congruent to each other
they are congruent to each other and
they are adjacent they share a common
endpoint so one definition that you
could make for kite is that you have
two
pairs
of congruent
congruent sides
where the congruent sides
where congruent sides are adjacent
congruent sides
are
adjacent
and you might say well what's the other
alternative if the congruent sides
aren't adjacent what else could they be
well the congruent sides could be
opposite each other and what happens if
you were to do that so if these two
sides are congruent but they weren't if
they didn't have a common endpoint we're
still dealing with a quadrilateral what
would it look like well you would have
one congruent side here
and that would be congruent to this side
right over here
and then you would have a congruent side
that is congruent to this side this
would be a situation where you have two
pairs of congruent sides but they're not
adjacent they don't have any common they
don't have any common endpoints with
each other each each each side and the
congruent side pair they are opposite to
each other so here once again we get a
quadrilateral we still get four sides a
kite is a quadratic this is a
quadrilateral but this isn't a kite this
right over here this right over here is
a parallelogram and we've seen that
multiple times before but kites can also
be constructed in other interesting ways
you might see that well it looks right
here that these these two diagonals of
this kite are perpendicular and that
indeed and i'm not going to prove it
here is a property of a kite this right
over here is a purp this is a perp these
two
lines these two diagonals intersect at a
90 degree angle
the other thing we know about kites is
that one of these lines is bisecting the
other of the two so you could actually
construct a kite that way
you could start with a line
and then you could construct a
perpendicular bisector of that line
another segment that bisects it at a 90
degree angle so here there you go
so that bisects it so that means that
this segment is equal to this segment we
split it into
and then if you connect the endpoints of
the segments
you should get a kite and you will
indeed get a kite
so it would look
it would look something
something like
something like this and once again this
segment is congruent to this adjacent
segment and this segment is congruent to
this adjacent segment
but what would happen if these two
diagonals are both perpendicular
bisectors of each other so what would
happen in this scenario
where
let me draw
one segment
and then i'm going to make another
segment but they're going to be
perpendicular bisectors of each other
so let's do that so now they're both
perpendicular bisectors of each other so
this segment is equal to this segment
and this segment is equal to this
segment
well now once again you still have a
kite
you still have a kite but now you're
also satisfying the constraint for
another type of quadrilateral that we've
seen
so now
you said you're satisfying the
constraint
all your sides are equal all of your
sides are parallel you're now dealing
with a rhombus which is also a special
type of parallelogram and then if you
were to go even further where these two
diagonals have the exact same length and
they're both perpendicular bisectors of
each other
so you have they're both the exact same
length i'll try to draw it as cleanly as
i can so they're both the exact same
length and they're both perpendicular
bisectors of each other
so each of these halves would be the
same length as well then you have a
subset of i guess i could say rhombi and
you get to a square
you
get to a square so one way of thinking
about it is
any square
is also a rhombus which is also going to
and any rhombus is also going to satisfy
your constraints for being a kite but
there's a bunch of kites that don't
satisfy your constraints of being a
rhombus of or a square a kite is just
two pairs of congruent sides that are
adjacent to each other and they're
usually pretty obvi pretty easy to spot
out because they look like kites